voyageur y sommes le train de nuit et
j'ai envie de le voir continuer ce
travail
après avoir failli disparaître le train
des nuits est aujourd'hui promis à une
renaissance dans une interview accordée
au parisien le 31 janvier jean baptiste
djebbari ministre des transports a
déclaré ambitionnait l'ouverture d'une
dizaine de lignes de trains de nuit à
l'horizon 2030
c'est le retour en grâce d'un mode de
transport apprécié de nombreux voyageurs
depuis des décennies pour son charme
comme ici en 1953 sur le sud express
reliant paris à l'espagne les wagons
lits sont placés sous la responsabilité
d'un conducteur qui veille sur les
voyageurs comme un bon père de famille
[Musique]
zabel des voyageurs est à la disposition
de chelsea pour un éventuel
et déjeuner ou une consommation de plus
cela sur la garde et la sécurité de la
voiture au cours des années 60 les
wagons ce modernisme et démocratise de
voyages de nuit auprès des français
cette de voiture est dotée de
l'isolation acoustique et phonique
l'équipement très complet de chaque
compartiment comporte notamment un coin
toilette avec eau courante chaudes et
froides prise de courant pour rasoir
électrique
un confort qui s'accompagne de service
agréable comme se faire apporter son
petit déjeuner dans le compartiment
et bien sûr il ya le wagon restaurant
dont le plus célèbre et le plus sélect
et celle du mythique train bleu qui
relie alors paris à la côte d'azur au
dîner le menu est à la carte et quelques
terrine de foie gras de canard truffé à
17 francs saumon fumé acs prend canard à
la danoise va francs un train propice à
la détente qui propose en 1975 un
service plutôt inhabituel le wagon
cinéma
[Musique]
mais dès les années 80 l'essor du tgv et
de l'avion entraîne le lent déclin du
train de nuit de moins en moins rentable
pour la sncf il reste malgré tout encore
plébiscité par ceux qui veulent voyager
pratique et économique
puis comme c'est un long voyage
ça permet de réduire les temps de
transport en fait après avoir quasiment
disparu en 2016 avec seulement deux
lignes encore en service
le train de nuit et aujourd'hui promis à
une nouvelle jeunesse on entendra donc à
nouveau la nuit sur les quais l'appel du
chef de train
[Musique]